sri lanka's political crisis is now
hitting citizens at the gas pump with
record high prices
in an effort to conserve fuel the
embattled government is asking people to
work from home and has close schools
restaurants have switched to cooking
meals with wood thousands of protesters
enraged by the country's worsening
economic crisis stormed the presidential
compound and the prime minister's
private home over the weekend both the
president and prime minister have agreed
to step down opposition leaders are
racing to form a new government
we take a closer look now at how the
crisis is affecting the lives of
citizens in the country's capital
colombo
for seven days
has been waiting here in a kilometer
long line for gas in sri lanka's capital
colombo
he'd heard a new fuel delivery was
coming he spent day and night here since
there is simply no more fuel
we have no more gas at home to cook
we used to have an income but for weeks
now the money has stopped coming
we can't go on like this
life is hard
to make matters worse his wife is ill
he tries to spend a little time with her
every day at lunchtime
risking losing his place in line
i keep calling him when he is there
waiting it's the tormenting thoughts
that have made me sick
i was even admitted to hospital
we didn't even have fuel for him to
drive me there
many people in sri lanka face similar
problems inflation is soaring and prices
are skyrocketing even for essentials
like food
hardly anyone can afford to buy what
they need
people used to have three meals a day
most of the time
now it's either two or one
sometimes people are drinking water
instead of eating
we don't know what to do what to give
our children they say they're hungry but
we don't have anything for them
we can't drink tea with milk anymore we
have no milk powder
we just about managed to buy rice but
even that is very expensive
another day has gone by in the line for
gas
and for azam
it's again been fruitless
his one hope that after the resignation
of president gotabaya rajapaksa better
times will finally come
only when we get problems like the fuel
crisis solved can we live a life worth
living
i haven't lost faith yet that a new
government will give us fresh hope and
change will finally happen
until then azam muhaddin will spend
another night in line hoping that he
will finally get a few litres of fuel
lawyer and human rights campaigner
pavani fonseca joins us from the center
for policy alternatives in colombo there
are reports that the president and his
brother are already attempting to leave
the country uh can you tell us how this
is going down with protesters
well what we've seen in the last few
days is quite remarkable in terms of the
numbers that have arrived at the protest
sites and as a result
we've seen the president agreeing to
resign as well as the prime minister
agreeing to resign they have yet to
resign and this is something we need to
keep in mind that a few days later
we still have a president and prime
minister holding on to office and now
it's been reported that the president
and his younger brother attempted to
leave sri lanka
we are waiting for verified information
but it also looks like people
at the airport as well as staff members
prevented them from leaving so there's
real anger and frustration among people
in sri lanka and it looks like people
also want
a reckoning from the political
leadership for the prison crisis
um i i want to bring us back to this
storming of the presidential palace the
the
footage we saw was absolutely amazing
was it a was it a clear sign
that that this is the end of president
rachael and his family's grip on
politics
well we need to keep in mind that the
protests started several months ago the
protest started in march and it's been
expanded and spread to different paths
of sri lanka and the demand has been
very much clearly for the resignation of
the president as well as the departure
of the rajapaksas from active politics
so the warning signs have been there
people have been peacefully protesting
for months what happened on saturday as
you quite rightly said was remarkable in
terms of the numbers that came out and
the fact that after months of protesting
they were able to breach and enter both
the presidential palace as well as the
official office the secretariat
so that sent a clear message that time
was up and the president had to resign
as well as the prime minister and in
that context it's still shocking that
they're still holding on to office
because the people have been very clear
with their demand
when it comes to the process of
appointing new political leaders
will they have the legitimacy to bring
about the political stability that's
needed in the country
well we are in a political and economic
crisis and stability is critical and
it's incumbent on anyone who's going to
take on the job that this is going to be
given priority to ensure that there is
economic recovery now it's going to be a
mammoth task as to whoever takes it on
how they're going to address this and it
will require a lot of attention and
support
but there's a clear path in terms of a
resignation of the president the
constitution provides for a clear path
there can be an acting prime minister
president who can be in office for 30
days and it's up to parliament to then
elect a member of parliament to serve
the remainder of the period so there's a
clear constitutional provision and a
pathway to address that whoever takes it
on
will also require the support of
parliament so their legitimacy will
really be dependent and will be tested
in the coming weeks and months as to
whether they are able to address it the
the opposition opposition leader has
come forward and said he he is
interested so the next few days are
going to be interesting and and fluid in
sri lanka palani fonseca thank you very
much for bringing us up to date on the
situation there